hey what's up everybody welcome
to another edition of hey babe
how you feeling i feel good i feel okay yeah
because you were telling me this i got what you do
what what'd my silly soul do okay i didn't do it
on purp what happened i bit not i was late night
i was looking for a snack they call it grazing i
think grazing yeah which just makes me feel like a
animal a cow yeah yeah i guess that's what it
is right is it made to feel you like they say
you shouldn't graze i think gray's you never
you ever see when i when i when a team football
team loses bad but the quarterbacks got like 500
yards like those are garbage yards yes they just
they were down they were just yeah i feel like
when you're grazing those are garbage calories
garbage calories on the grazing yeah you're
not but also yes grazing yeah but also you know
the most in shape people and like the skinniest
people i know and the most rich people they graze
all day they never eat like one big meal they're
eating their calories like every couple of years
away to graze probably you know small meals
throughout the day keep your matab going
what you want to do what you want to do if
you can is keep your diet in the gray zone
the great you want to stay in the graze zone
gray zone in the gray zone life is great it's
almost dangerous though if you're not if you're
not uh calculating it that's why you have the
fitness palette i know but you got it you got
to be careful because you know what you'll do
you'll graze and you'll forget i know i i swear
to god you have you ever say i'll enter it later
then you go to enter your calories at the end of
the day yeah oh and then it's bad because you're
not supposed to do that but then you go and
you go oh i just blew the doors off today yeah
no the one couple of times i've done that i
genuinely multiple times in my life since i
was doing this fitness brow thing i've blown
my load on breakfast i've eaten 2 000 calorie
breakfast many many times in my life you've
been doing the fitness app though yeah but now
i don't as much and now i just have a ziggy's
yogurt yeah ziggy's is great shadow chicken
you know what's great ziggy's a little saratoga
peanut butter oh god bless you sarah tokes this
is our our weekly shout out i don't think we shot
him out last year by the way coming your way very
soon we're getting our own saratoga peanut butter
it's happening proceeds going to charity we will
let you know as soon as that's available we are
literally thinking of the flavor right now we're
in the throes of producing this we got to think
of a label we're going to think of the flavor we
might be doing a no press pack no pressure pack
yeah i it's funny how you literally do another
podcast with the great with our great friend joe
derosa called taste buds that's about food but
yet we're the one that plugged the food we plugged
the food all day on this show we plug everything
all day long i saw one of the last episodes with
derosa on taste buds i brought it up because i
we just found out the information pimp told me
i'm like oh my god because we were doing peanut
butter and jelly versus grilled cheese right
i mean where do you go peanut butter jelly
that's where i went i won't say who won but
that's where i freaking went peanut butter jelly
i don't i don't like grilled cheese i don't i
can't eat by the way i can only eat cheese if
it's melted i can't eat and we'll never eat cold
cheese that's insane there's never once in my life
that i've ever been out anywhere and ordered
a cold cheese platter even p taken a piece of
cold cheese if you melt it and put it on put on
a sandwich on a sandwich if i'm being 100 crystal
clear honest with you though i really only eat
cheese on pizza egg and cheese and cheeseburgers
i would never i've never eaten cold cheese and
i've i would say in my life you don't snack on
cheese less intention he's bored you don't love
peeling out oh a single american yellow american
and just throwing it in the mouth i've done it mo
i've done it maybe what is it surf sufferers of
of tourophobia turophobia associate cheese with a
traumatic memory what happened to you with cheese
no nothing i don't think that's the mozzarella
phobes often have to run away if they so much
see a slice of cheese yeah some may fear one
type of cheese while others may fear cheese all
together no dude idahomeophobia comprises often
irrational excessive fear of sleep i've eaten
less than 10 grilled cheeses in my entire life
that is raw that's star in buckwild yes 97. hot
shout out hot 97 shout out morning show shout out
breakfast club i'll shout them all out c100 yeah
yeah everybody yeah star from starring buckwild
would always say uh i'm in a conundrum he would
always say that oh yeah oh no he's always saying
i mean a quagmire quagmire he would say quagmire
he said i have a quagmire yeah um you don't love
cheese i do love cheese but it has to be melted
what about a beautiful tray of fresh mozzarella
never in my i've never in my life eaten one chris
but i've only ever had it on a sandwich
is it is it keto fresh around by the way
well it's low carbs low sugar so yes i
i i've owned i've never i've had fresh
mozzarella but only on the same plate
with a little balsamic drizzle maybe a
sweet road roasted maybe i've had that
twice steak tomato or something on hello
maybe twice in my life i've had that wow what
about burrata that i don't know every burrata
with fig and maybe pine nuts and you mix it up
and you dip a nice crostini into it i'm going
to be 100 honest with you again not only have
i never had burrata i've never heard of bharata
have you heard of burrata pimp what do you
mean broad is on every menu ever it's like
it's almost like a fresh mozzarella it's a creamy
cheese never heard of it you had stretchertella
wait wait wait wait wait wait because you know
what it is now you found out you're mostly german
not german yeah you did the 23andme you're
99 german i never mine i was never in my life
you don't know what burrata cheese is though
burrata like i never seen it on a menu even
you've never heard the word i don't think i've
ever heard anyone looking down on you i'm just
uh i'm not i'm not throwing stones here i'm
just saying like i thought i i maybe i'm
maybe i'm wrong maybe i thought that the
people knew what that was they sell it in
the supermarket the cheeses that i've heard of
i'm being serious american cheese swiss cheese
monster cheese mozzarella cheese as many as you
can okay american cheese swiss cheese monster
cheese uh uh um uh mozzarella cheese buffalo
mozzarella cheese okay mozzarella cheese and um
and blue cheese yeah blue cheese but you've heard
of gorgonzola gorgonzola provolone yes uh cheddar
cheddar goat cheese goat cheese uh uh uh uh
uh what's that other one with that uh um it's
a little spicy jack pepper jack jack you heard of
that yes yeah you heard of uh uh you said monster
i mean what other types of cheeses are there uh
well there's so many though there's like sheep
sheep's milk cheese i'll never eat anything from
a sheep okay well this is cheese but what about
ricotta cheese ricotta cheese i've had you've had
that with a little honey though you've had that
cold never with honey okay okay but i've never
even heard of burrata yeah well burana burrata
b-u-r-r-a-t-a i believe no never heard of it the
art of cheese making is referred to in ancient
greek mythology and evidence of cheese and cheese
making has been found on egyptian tomb murals
dating back over 4 000 years oh and obviously my
favorite cheese of all time and i forgot cheese
whiz yeah that's probably oh yeah that's different
than burrana that you know cheese may have been
discovered accidentally by the practice of storing
milk and containers made of just the stomachs of
animals because that is cheese is pretty much
just old dirty milk like what is cheese i don't
know but it's freaking good that's curdling milk
except the milk is curdled on purpose most cheese
is made in factors after milk is poured into
big vats a starter culture of bacteria is added
to convert the lactose into lactic acid which is
also what builds up when you're exercising and why
you feel pain in your muscles that's true then an
enzyme called rennet is added to curdle the milk
you you don't eat cheese that's not hot or
melted and you've never heard of burrata cheese
it has to be melted it's i could or i've i could
have ordered us burrata cheese for lunch well i'll
tell you this i'll tell you this and i should
have burrata for the first time on the podcast
100 that in a pork chop that's it i just said
patreon wall i just patreon coming soon i just
hundred percent here's what we're doing with the
patreon too we're gonna make a list so that when
patreon actually does have oh my god events
it's an event it's gonna be like the super
bowl speaking of super bowl congrats tom brady
and the bucks that's it i'm gonna say congrats
to kansas city chiefs that's it congrats
chiefs and mahomes and everybody else kelsey
and hill and all those guys what happened was yes
the super bowl's like just in case just in case
we got those two congrats to both teams for the
first time super bowl history there's been a tie
a tie can you believe it yes i was go you
know what i would tell the babies we don't
know who's gonna win obviously we don't uh it's
happening momentarily but it is a crazy story for
brady yes to leave new england they don't make the
playoffs the super bowl is in tampa yeah he makes
a run with gronkowski in his last couple of years
with a different i mean that that is the story
you know i mean you know the chiefs are young
hungry they won last year they have a bright
future ahead of them yes i don't think brady needs
any more rings but it is a story it's about to
happen it's that already happened you already
know this is like them watching in the they're
in the future from us that's it and they're
looking back in time this i literally think
tom brady not only taking his team for the first
year uh first time uh tampa bay bucks first year
with the team to the super bowl wild card mind
you facing the one seed wild card facing the
one seed and the first time in super history
that the home team is hosting super only that
would only happen to tom brady 100 like that's
literally tom brady it's literally the tampa
bay bucks and tom brady are the luckiest team
but then the fans i feel like the most unlucky
the only time it ever happens in super bowl
history the fans can't even go to the stadium
yeah how about this one 20 000 tom brady 43 years
old oldest active player in the nfl i'm older than
him wow i'm older than every last player in the
nfl can you believe that that's insane it's crazy
and i watch the nfl and i think these guys are
my heroes and they could be my sons they're going
to be your sons no when you wear a jersey when
you were because you're a huge steelers fan um
when you wear a uh uh um juice jersey i mean that
guy he's it's almost it's portland pedophilia
stage when he was born no no it's it's a it's
almost a crime scenario it is yeah that's that's
what it is no but listen you know did i ever tell
you the story about uh i'm wasted by the way off
this whiskey this is amazing do you ever tell
you the story about aaron rodgers aaron rodgers
if you're watching him we know
that you are yeah um aaron rodgers
is is a great dude i i actually years ago
i mean i mean years i i i my guess is maybe
uh i don't know five six years ago uh somehow
we connected and uh he wrote to me on uh we were
starting to dm and talking and nice guy that's a
nice that's a nice thing to wake up to a little
dmv man rogers great pretty cool right hundred
percent i like i think uh like i like we were
following each other on twitter and i just like
we reached out and i was like uh he's like i like
the show and i'm like yeah you're aaron rodgers so
that's pretty cool like yeah holy [ __ ] right and
then that's like one time i got that's like one
time i got a dm from drake and i just thought it
was like i was like oh my god it was like love
your comedy and then i was like thanks so much
and they're like yeah i love that thing you did
with eminem he meant to send it to chris dalia
did you ever tell that to delete no he's got
a shout out from jesus no i never told that
and you know another thing that happened to me and
crystalia one time i got invited i this i told him
i got invited to go literally fl sal flown
across the country from new york city to
seattle washington got paid a handsome amount to
do a corporate gig handsome out to do a corporate
gig because they had flown me out thinking i go
it's you know whatever college college kids party
somebody's 21st birthday the father of the girl
had paid me real money messaged me everything
flew me out did that i performed they thought it
was cr he thought i was crystalia his daughter and
their friend's favorite comedian was chris delea
not me so i get on stage they thought i was just
waiting for crystalline 35 minutes to show i say
good night one of the girls says when is chris
dalia coming and then i go back and say i said
excuse me what do you mean crystal yeah and then
the father says honey he that's him christy comedy
christy comedy so that's happened to me twice
and you and you took a handsome you took
a handsome amount i took to leah's money
i told him and he was like hey buddy keep it i
got plenty of money today were they happy in the
end or were they like fine here's the thing but i
got to be honest with you the first 20 minutes i
was struggling i didn't know why i was doing that
material you know i was like these usually work
yeah so that's that two times that happened damn
yeah yeah so so so i'm talking to aaron rodgers
right this is okay this is right every single
thing i'm telling you not a single exaggeration
yeah we're going back you don't exaggerate no
you don't exactly i really try not to you can't
you you every time you tell me a story you never
have i most i usually have to say i promise you
i i take a lot of licenses it's pretty straight up
you're one of my most trustworthy friends and the
homeless yeah yeah no but you gotta extrapolate a
little too that's part of it but is this this i'm
telling you right now bare bones are the story so
we start trading you know messages and everything
he's actually really funny dude uh right away we
were like kind of like busting each other's chops
a little bit it was like that kind of vibe so i go
to la by chance in la i'm visiting an old friend
of mine he's like how you been how you doing
what's up what's new and we're just bullshitting
and i say oh you know like he said have you i
think he asked me like what's the coolest thing
that's happening as of late and i'm like i'll
tell you one i've been talking to aaron rodgers
isn't that great wild crazy right yeah funny guy
nice guy get the hell out of it i swear to god
like the aaron rodgers pretty cool he's a fan
he likes the show all that stuff wow wow great
so then we'll walk uh so we're walking and my
friend's like let's go get a coffee he works
shout out dom di bartolomeo of of of
domenico's foods out in our livestream
you know him yeah he works at the beverly hills
wine and cheese shop but he also has his own line
of foods great food just look up domenico's
uh italian foods on instagram and check out
dom dipatoloma so he's my friend since
high school i've known him 31 years so
he's like let's go get a cappuccino or whatever
so we'll walk into this little place he knows
and he's like uh and people are saying hello to
me and stuff so he's like oh that that must does
it get annoying do you like how do you feel about
that i think it's not bad it's par for the course
you know and he's i'm like sometimes it could
be a little intrusive because if people won't
really want to talk to you they don't realize that
like you can't stop for everyone it's taking up a
lot of your time yeah my favorite interaction is
when someone just yells from a course you're like
hey by the way keep going can i just real
quick we'll get back to story but just because
you reminded me two days ago i swear to god i
was driving so i was walking somebody driving
by in a van was stopped at a red light and i'm
crossing the street and they go oh oh what's
up they said you got that podcast you got the
podcast with the joker i said yeah he goes yeah
he goes i love it he goes what's it called uh hey
something you and joe gatto you and joe gotto that
he's going you and joan gatto he goes you and
joe gotta would i love it i love it and then
i just kept moving i was like absolutely that's
it yeah that's hysterical i swear to god he goes
and then he just went through the light
so so i i tell them you know what i really
i really prefer when someone's just like
oh we're pulling up we're pulling up dm's
patreon if you want to hear the real [ __
] yeah if you want to see the story if you
want to see the pics that were sent yeah so
so this is this is truthfully all right so
so you have the proof no but not that this timing
where do you hear this right because this is
balls will be blown off i can't wait to get my
balls blown off you should have no balls after
this well listen i'm already as i've told you many
times i'm already kind of angling to get the sex
changes that's why i'm doing this podcast yes if
you blow my balls up with the story halfway give
you money exactly so here's what happens so i tell
him my favorite interaction when people just don't
even break shot and go how you doing i say what
do you say yeah keep going so i'm telling you
well i should call him up he uh i mean first of
all if you call aaron rodgers right now i'll come
so i meant dom but sure same dude 20 seconds 20
seconds after i said that a car drives by here
say i go hey what do you say and the car keeps
driving i go there you go i go that right there
my ideal situation all right we get to the coffee
place order a couple cappuccinos sit down we're
drinking the coffee just shooting the [ __ ]
my pocket buzzes i go i look i got a dm from
aaron rodgers in that moment he goes what are
you too good to say hello i said what are you
telling me goes that was me that just drove by
in the car yelling at you on rodeo drive i was
like you're [ __ ] kidding me right now he's like
no that was me i go dude come back yeah i i look
at my friend and go you're not gonna believe this
the person that just screamed hey what do you say
drive by that was my idea was aaron rodgers
was super bowl winning nvp talking about him
yes he drove by in a car and beeped he's not from
l.a i'm not from l.a we were both visiting he
was going to a meeting i was visiting a friend i
was speaking about him he drove past me in a car
in the state that both of us had known not to be
from and said and beeped at me i couldn't frickin
believe it can you believe that do me a favor
right now feel go deep go yeah tell me if you
feel my balls there's no balls there blown off
blown away blown off i mean this kid just gave
you money i saved you money does it take a step up
from here that's because my balls i don't have any
balls i was just gonna read you i mean that's
insane this is okay this this particular date
was february 27 2017. so four years ago basically
february 27 2017. that was me that that was me and
the bmw that just yelled at you in beverly hills
thanks for the wave sl the wave slash blow off
holy smokes what are you doing
out here and then we go on i said
in all caps that was you oh i don't have
my glasses which i didn't did he come back
no he uh yes it was really so funny he was
gonna come see me do stand up actually but
he had a 5 30 appointment at this point it
was already uh 3 30 so he couldn't come back
performing tonight tomorrow and then after that
he blew me off but god bless him uh no didn't
leave you on scene he busted my chops about the
jaden tattoo and then head to that for like two
years every mother's day and father's day i texted
i texted him happy mother's day happy father's day
hey and he always responds thank you thank
you oh is that same to you yeah yeah does he
give a [ __ ] for being a stealers fan or no i
don't know if we've ever talked about that yeah
but yeah i was rude i i always i'm rooting
for him whenever i can shout out aaron rodgers
mother's day or father's day because i just
thought it was like i just i don't know it was
just instinctively i was like we we break we break
each other's shoes a little bit so i'll just text
him and because he's he we joke he was he was
he showed me that he he would understand that
joke and he does hold on sal always does stuff
like that remember you met you always you send
my dad my father birthday you sent him a birthday
gift once remember it was like january when i told
you my dad's birthday is august 1st you sent him
a gift on his birthday wait hold on you know what
it's funny about what i did with your dad yeah i
go um i go your dad's birthday's coming i want to
send him a gift card in the mail right yeah so you
you're like yes and i go you know who do i dress
it to and you wrote kazoo yeah a text message to
me you're right just addressed it a cousin but i
read that as like for some reason no
relation to lizzo by the way yeah yeah
as like like i i was like i thought it was maybe
like your dad's like nickname or whatever what he
goes by yeah i thought it was like his last name
like no i don't know i know his last name is the
stefano but like i don't know i just took it as
an italian i don't know he walked out pimps walked
off the set for some reason i i wrote i sent it
to your dad and i wrote kazoo yeah as the as the
mailing address right i wrote as his name and then
the rest of it and remember like two months later
it got sent back to me i sent you a picture of it
yeah i bet you if you look in your text messages
it's the thing i said no but i got a new phone
since then i gotta upload my stuff to the icloud
the aaron rodgers thing is is yeah it makes you
happy mother's day aaron he wrote back same to
you sal how's the tattoo treating you you're a
great mother and then and then and then then on
father's day wrote happy father's day aaron and
he's like thanks so much for the father's day
wishes mentis happy father's day to you too hope
you got a message from jaden sunday you deserve it
he's a funny guy top-notch guy top-notch guy
top-notch get him out let's get him on the podcast
sure you know who died oh you you know recently
siegfried died of sick freedom roy siegfried
oh yes i did know that sick freeze is roy dead
or anything roy got eaten by the tiger nobody
lived but then roy died not a little while back
complications from the tiger no okay i don't know
no he's both dead he didn't die at the hands
of his hike or mordecai or something like that
yeah but roy horn but god bless but here's
what i thought was pecul you ready did you
know sig freedom roy if that was their first
name their last name i i personally always
thought that siegfried and roy weren't either
one of their names they just came up with the
stage name and they said siegfried and roy real
names uh they were actual life partners as well
as magic partners did you know that they were in
a homosexual relationship they were two lifelong
homosexuals in a relationship together that also
dealt with lions on the side by the way that's
insane to me and isn't that a isn't that wonderful
you just get to make money and may and and do all
this great stuff see the world with your life part
with your husband it's like what we're venturing
it's like what we're doing yeah yeah that's like
what we're doing it is and and it's kind of like
yeah it's just a taste though we don't have tigers
and we don't have 200 million dollars and we're
not having sex at night no but if you take just
those three on the patreon no differences you mean
you no if you take no sex take away 200 mil and
tigers with sick freedom we're sick free to rise
yeah yeah but do you know what their names are
that is their real names roy is roy horn roy hoyne
regular which is like two two single syllables
boom boomers are they american horn are they men
no i think they're german german and his name's
roy horn well let me tell you about siegfried's
last name you ready for its name this threw me for
a loop and i kind of understand why they went with
their first names only okay bendelbaum totally
joke bocker fishbacher siegfried fishbacher and
roy horn siegfried fishbacher one can only
imagine if they went by horn and fish bocker
if they would have seen the same successes yeah
that's one of those things when you go into the
office and then to your new magical fish boxer
fish bonker and horn what do you think that's a
fish marker horn attorney's a law yeah that's what
it sounds like yeah one eight hundred and eight
you know i'm saying that 100 mattresses i'm just
trying to sing selena and barnes which is eight
local injury attorneys that you guys might not
know i don't know maybe barnes died in a plane
god bless god bless you i gotta be honest
with you shout out selena and barnes barn
signing plane crash celino put a sign up with
just celino real quick yeah he did he did but
what are you gonna do that's a good point i mean
i mean you gotta do it i mean we're not judging
here to judge selena and get a lawsuit slapped on
us yeah that's the last thing i want to do after
seeing the commercials they transition from magic
to tigers bringing tigers around what no wait
you seek freedom roy we're talking about
selena and barnes seleno and barnes are
two accident attorneys that that made their
made their living in new york that have blown up
it would be a funny thing that i'm stuck on the
line training fish parker and horn yeah they they
fish horn one of them was dealing in lions and
one was dealing in magic and then they met and
then they combined the two that's right they
were by the way siegfried and roy discovered
in paris who asked him to come to vegas in 1967
and this was just thrown into the wikipedia
they spent some time in puerto rico
and may have purchased property there
doing a deep dive i don't know what the point of
that was but they just wanted to tell you that
puerto rico they of course they spent time there
and they may or may not have purchased property
there find out on the patreon what the answer is
here's what i want from our listeners i want you
to take things that we say and apply them in your
life to make your life unique and special for
example in the future when sick freedom roid
comes up in your life it's going to come up
right everyone has heard endor said
the name sigrid and roy in their lives
in seven years from now you might overhear someone
talking about sick freedom i've never heard of
burrata cheese i've heard of sick freedom
right correct yeah what i want you to do is
whenever that is for you it's a ticking time bomb
for all of you if it's in a month in 10 years in
20 years when someone breaks up sick freedom roy i
want you to go you know they purchased property in
puerto rico i want you to have that information
handy and it's factual and i want you to say it
yeah so siegfried so oh roy wasn't born roy check
that out can you want to do you want to take a
stab at that name his name was oohy ludwig horn or
maybe it's you you ludwig horn it's spelled u-w-e
well there you go listen they had a 2005 animated
sitcom they had a sitcom called father of the
prize so you guys are a lot of more right you
guys you're like more like sick freed fishbacher
and roy horn than you realized then i realized
you had an animated thing about fatherhood i had
an item anything about father and i had a pi they
actually made it to air though in 2004. i'm still
i was crazy pilots i'm just so confused so they
as open micros would bring tigers around what do
you mean open micros pimp pip showing his age
right now pimp is 19 and a half i don't know
if you ever told you guys that yeah pimp is 19
and a half he knows tech like yeah he doesn't
yeah he doesn't know pimp doesn't know who pimp
thinks sick reader right now or over my comedians
who started toying with tigers are you
saying that or are you saying when they were
nobody knew who they were were they just coming
out with we got lions how do you transition
like how do you get into the line what i had
heard was and i don't want to mix them up but
i think one of them like let's call a fishbacker
was into magic he met roy roy was heavy into lions
he was heavy into it and then they were
like let's do let's combine them together
i read this in the wake of sigfried's passing i
read an article maybe in the times or something
right yeah are there still questions i'm happy to
feel them yeah i mean just what's the logistics
of bringing tigers on the road yeah it can't
be oh i mean well they weren't really on the
road the whole show was in las vegas well that
was after they made their boat they made their
they've been on las vegas though about for 30 or
40 years i think they're worth like like a couple
of billion dollars oh well yeah and then in 2003
they did the show at the mirage which i never got
a chance to see did you ever see it the show i
did not that's yeah we could watch it on youtube
they uh allegedly in october 3rd 2003 great year
accord not mordecai um montecore attacked roy horn
um because horn held the microphone up to
montague's mouth and told him to say hello to the
audience which montague found that offensive and
responded which lions could if i asked you to say
hello and you're a lion you may or may not do what
monochord did monochord then responded by biting
horn sleeve and horn swatted tiger and barked
release and then realized quickly that this tiger
doesn't know english and then horn ripped and
then horn ripped its arm out of the tiger's mouth
and montecura moved to stand over him so monticur
bit into horn's neck and dragged him off stage
yeah i know that and i think there was footage at
the time although recently when i read the article
and i searched for the footage again sue me is i i
didn't find it so they might have stripped it from
the internet because it you know the warning
it is it is something and then it's a site
and then here too because you know obviously as
we've mentioned as we mentioned um siegfried and
roy were in a homosexual relationship montecore
was uh no different because it says trainers got
the tigers to release uh horn by spraying the
tiger with co2 because that tiger was flaming so
we we now know from episode four of hey babe they
can be gay animals they can be gay animals and
montague was a gay gay gay animal that could only
be stopped by you know getting the flames out with
co2 and then that was the last resort available
but horn's uh spine he got his he's got a severed
spine massive blood loss and injured all he got it
ended his career montgomery ended his career yeah
so and then he also had a stroke either before or
after montgomery dragged him off stage i mean this
bad news yeah but he recovered and they
spent some years after that happily and uh
i think they they they retired from the show in
vegas but anyway shout out to sick freedom roy
um and here's here's the thing is an interesting
thing here's how you know the kid loved animals
roy horn said montague is a great cat make sure
no harm comes to manchester he actually saved
my life by trying to drag me to safety after i
had a stroke yeah and maybe that's what he said
you know and he knows better than us about that if
he had the stroke i mean from me from my point of
view i don't think that's what happened but also
he's the professional what came first the chicken
of the egg right what came first the stroke of the
bite i mean horn i mean there's got you think horn
i hope a horn and and fish and siegfried
like they had like a playful relationship
you got to think in any of their sexual
escapades together in the four decades
that they loved each other right you think you
think roy made any jokes about blowing his horn
and things like that yeah time to get the you
know it's time to the horn section needs a jab
like that i would have i mean you gotta i mean
you gotta be playful right i'm not gonna to my
own horn here get on your knees kind of thing
right yeah yeah yeah no no zero disrespect
i'm trying to get into like the real sexual play
i'm just saying like you know you have a partner
when you're playful in in in in the throes of
passion it's always short you know always fun
it makes you feel closer together it's not just
you're not just going in there doing a job no
you know you're still your normal selves your own
personalities i wonder if horn right was a playful
fellow and then ever never did double entendres
with his last name and blowing you know you know
i don't see i don't i'd like to believe it i
don't see one but then also we're assuming that
they're speaking in english when they're in the
throes i mean if they're german guys they might
be speaking in the german language having sex that
is true so we like to have a lot of sometimes we
like to have fun on the heads uh but this one i'm
just gonna read word for word at least the first
part hey fellas we're in the thick of winter and
the storms are brewing it looks like one to three
inches are in the forecast when you trim that
hibernation bush that's taking place in your pants
luckily our partners at manscape specialize in
products to make sure you're walking around town
with beautiful snowballs manscaped is here to
provide you the best tools for your grooming
experience offering precision engineered tools
for your family jewels i'll i'll tell you what
the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer i'm being dead serious
it says the best hygiene tool for the modern man
they're a thousand percent right i have that
lawnmower 3.0 that it's literally to the skin
shave i no nick nothing it's so s my balls right
now look like michael jordan yeah i'm telling you
really yes your balls look like a six-year-old
black man yes wow the lawnmower 3.0 championship
six rings michael jordan that's what my balls
look like from the lawn mower three points 3.0
now let me dance on that i wonder what happened to
the people who who had the 1.0 on the 2.0 i don't
know what happened to them godspeed if you have
that and you love it you got to know that the 3.0
is what you got but even better right they have
another thing called the crop preserver preserver
which is an anti-chafing ball deodorant that make
your balls smell nice and make you feel like your
testes are walking into winter wonderland well
that's always fun i love it all you got to do
is go to manscape.com hey babe you're going to get
20 off plus free shipping that's manscape.com and
uh uh we just want to say thanks manscape
for making our winter weenies look so great
so sal i really the last like couple of weeks
i've been really having like a rock hard penis
for most of the day interesting because i've
been using bluetooth i've been using because
i had those problems when i i couldn't get my
penis up and nothing i do it just my dick would
it just wouldn't go up but now i've been going to
bluechew.com and i put in the promo code hey babe
and i've been getting it for free no that's not
nothing in this life is free well you get five
dollars off shipping no that's not true at all you
spend five dollars for shipping and you get it for
free you spend five dollars i was setting you up
to be like no there is things in life that you
get for free and then i thought you were gonna hit
them with the great deal that we have for them but
we floundered and we're not gonna edit this out
because we're men of the people because women are
the people and i'm proud to stand by my erection
and if you just go to bluetooth.com promo code hey
babe yes then what exactly you're going to do you
try it for free you you get your first shipment
free and and then you just pay five beans for
the shipping that's it so you're paying for the
shipping you're getting the product for free you
can't beat that that you can't beat think about
the the ads we do 10 off 20 off no you just that
the other this is free free promo code hey babe
pay five dollar shipping bluetooth.com that's it
what's up it's chrissy standups listen february
12th 13th valentine's day weekend i'll be doing
atlantic city new jersey the celebrity theater
then february 25th to the 27th hot hot hot phoenix
arizona house of comedy then just added march 6
the vogel red bank new jersey we just added two
shows there go get em the tickets sold out real
quick last time go to chrisdcomedy.com
for tickets that's chrisdcomedy.com for
tickets some chrissy standups let's have some
fight yan possible and yeah you're right maybe
oh yeah joe exotic i mean joe exotic doesn't let's
be honest i'm a fan of jokes i doesn't hold the
candle the sick freedom roy no he doesn't do magic
no but he's with the animal zone the tigers yeah
he thought he was to get out of jail with trump
but trump didn't get paid he had a limo outside
the pardon that did not come through what can
you what what so now he's got to spend you know
a lot more time in jail but i mean what can you
do best now let me ask you this question real
quick uh you have to pick one person's hair joe
exotic dog the bounty hunter who do you go with
i'm gonna put i'm gonna put three of the
variations in the same cut i'm gonna put
a third one in to make it even harder
yeah you have to pick one haircut you
have to pick one right now think of it as like an
impractical jokes challenge you have to pick one
joe exotic dog the bounty hunter
long island medium who you going
oh one of the three long island medium
teresa caputo god bless us she has the uh
i mean i haven't seen her recently i wonder if
let's pull it up the one you're talking about
is like the bob cut maybe we'll gonna put up
right here this is the one i'd like yeah wow
wow so we going long island medium wow dog to
bounty hunter or joe exotic you have to pick one
go for it well teresa computer i grew up around
that haircut i grew up in staten island that
hiccup was a bound that's statin on my haircut
i had to choose one well i mean i want to say
that her excuse feminine at least well you know
who has that haircut chris angel yeah the angel
also has that that's it that's just if it's black
it's gonna say yeah all right oh my god someone
asked them to actually put dog and and joe exotic
together uh where do i go you know what because
dogs is back i think i want to go forward i think
i would i might take joe exotic joe exotic looks
like i'm i'm taking chances at the salon right
but dog looks like i did this at home myself
and i stand by it right so i think i want to be
the guy who like oh i told him to spruce me up i
wanted to try something different which i think
is joe exotic then this is me born and raised
is who i am that'll be my haircut in my casket
solid solid answer i think joe exotic's in a
phase solid right and you you're like know who you
are more so you'll be gold dog the bounty hunter
no no you're saying wait you're saying we're
probably gonna take dogs i think dogs is more like
this is all i know but there's comfort and
calmness in that that is true this is who i
am yeah yeah i feel like i feel like with dog the
bounty hunter all i have to do is if i just cut
the back of his hair he'd have a normal haircut
where joe exotic you have to eat he really you
have to shave joe exotic's head and start off
right right right you have to just kind of wipe
it off the map and say let's just begin by the
way long island medium and i have the same lawyer
entertainment lawyer and there have been multiple
times you know her daughter yeah when i've been
really yeah very interesting does she is she also
a medium no right but uh she's the smallest show
and i think that the whole thing is just cut that
part out what's that i said cause she said you
know her daughter i said oh she's a small cause
no i said is she a medium and you said no i said
she is small don't cut that but it's terrific let
me tell you something right now i love a dad joke
as much as a regular joke because i like to try
to make the most corny joke and to me that's a
success when you do it i've been doing them too
much though lately i'm a professional stand-up
comedian but because we haven't been having
that much stage time because of the bandy wendy
yeah i've been i've been floating a few dad jokes
out as but as you know as regular on stand-up and
it's you know and people are doing dad jokes
at stand up just you know but i'm just saying
like things like that like i mean you know i mean
if we were doing stand-up still i don't i think
in my head i wouldn't say oh don't do the
small joke but because there's no other time
to joke i said oh the long island small you
know it's just what can you do the way dog
dog the bounty understands by his haircut i stand
by the joke even though i'm not proud of you you
should stand by the joke and you should be proud
of it um long island medium real quick and i have
the same lawyer is that the guy from the goonies
the guy from the goonies shout out jeff cohen yeah
and there's been a couple times where we've been
on calls and he's had to go because he said oh i
gotta go i have a meeting with the long island
medium and he'd say that and multi what does
he drop before i didn't know the professional
business before i didn't know before i didn't
know that it was the long island medium uh before
i didn't know that he was his lawyer i thought he
was having like he was talking along and meeting
him like paying for his services talking to ghosts
and i was like my lawyer's a real kook but it was
they were having meetings like about big business
media makes a lot of money for 30 minutes seance
yeah um do you think the guy i want to call him by
respectful is it jeff you said jeff you think jeff
is sick and tired i'd be calling the guy from the
gummies because if he is and he's watching
him we know he is just like everybody else
um jeff actually might be no no offense please i
i actually i've heard that he's a million people
i know his lawyer jeff cohen i don't mean to call
you because i can't stand that too like one of the
best entertainment best entertainment lawyer uh
i've ever had have you guys seen this new trend
no please no no please bad chris that's not real
wait real quick let me just say with jeff cohen
real quick um because you said did he ever
get you know uh he was the kid right right
the truffle shuffle so when i first signed with
him we had a we had a meeting uh in his office
and he said look there's a picture of it in his
office yeah no no he said you know you know you
know truffle shelf you know from the goonies
and all that i see he goes listen i'll do this
for all my clients should i do it i'll just do it
once he goes i'll do the truffle shuffle for you
and then that's it you can't ask me again lifts
up your shirt does it drop the shuffle talk to
shirt back in south down went over the contract
no yes ask anybody who's jeff's you didn't ask
no he he volunteered and then did it did it and
he's ripped now so it doesn't even look he's got
abs so ask anybody who's who's a client of his you
were like listen you know what he knocks it out in
the first meeting yeah which is great because then
i never thought to ask again right otherwise you
were just thinking about one day that i could ask
him and i was by the way i was never going to ask
so now you can get your house verified is that
what we're talking about bluecheckhomes.com
what does that even mean though what are we
talking about here okay you can now get a verified
badge crest on your bay area home if you're an
influencer public figure or represent a brand
bluecheckhomes.com why that is the worst thing
i've that is right now i'm telling you right
now this is the beginning of the apocalypse
somebody's going to get killed the goddamn
apocalypse that they would put a disgusting corny
blue check on their homes and identify themselves
and their homes and their privacy as someone who
influences there is a publicly by the way look at
the house you do what what does it even matter but
yeah and it's also like pull up i mean you know no
disrespect at all but like pull up the house on
the right that one like in the picture we have
i mean this is an attached kind of piece of [ __
] house it's like you're verified but you've got
i mean i mean what are we doing you live in a
two-floor walk up here that's crazy that you're
putting a blue check no disrespect on the front
no disrespect there it is put some disrespect on
guys what are you doing why does this hold value
with you what is why are you letting the people
that are passing by in a car know that on social
media someone verified you what does that even
mean what is the point of it pimp do we have any
idea you're just afraid of it actually catching
on right now it seems like somebody's just
throwing it out there so it's been spotted though
can you click on bluejackhomes.com we're giving
them would you ever in a million never the blue
verified badge on your house lets people outside
know that you're an authentic public figure why
would you want to do that you want your home
to be your safe space in your privacy yet to
receive the blue check crest there must be someone
authentic and notable actively living in the house
who gives a sh what does that do besides identify
to someone that you may be on a social media app
by the way to be verified you don't have
to be famous you have to know somebody at
instagram or twitter like what does that even do
though that alerts someone that on social media
someone acknowledged that you have a business
it's like service safe actually yeah like what
a weird freaking thing to do man people have
their priorities messed up just do me if they
put me on the waiting list yeah i feel like it
just helps people target you to rob you yeah
how much money does that cost too what is
that thousands of dollars unsightly as well
it's a big blue check on the front of your home
it's gross i mean sure i mean are we gonna start
the application you better believe we are um
all right we gotta get it we're gonna do it
we'll get one well yeah that's what we do that's
why you guys you know maybe you hang it right out
the window yeah but we'll hang it right here oh
yeah right here was freaking studios verified
um so wait a second all right we're signing up
for the blue check hello but wait we started
off talking we started off talking about you
had a bad night last night oh my god dude
so i went to grace wentz grace and i
had some trader joe's organic mozzarella
okay in the fridge shredded so i went in there
it's like two and like two in the morning i i
had a i didn't really have a snack i didn't know
years ago you weren't you weren't waking up to pee
because you don't wake up to pee i don't wake up
at all never never and by the way you getting up
to get a snack there's a lot of things that have
to happen you have to unhook your face man i don't
know i i should say i wasn't sleeping i was in bed
watching tv there's a difference you know and then
i was like i didn't have a little snack and i
had a little rumbling and i didn't want to go
overboard so i was like what's something i could
do that will satiate me right so i took a scoop
put it in my mouth i mentioned my nuts through my
pocket but just know that it's i'm just i'm sorry
oh no yeah you got nuts now all of a sudden oh
that's right they came back they grew back these
guys lying to me and you two are faces they grew
back it's well documented that i blew them off
with aaron rodgers uh you're right didn't aaron
rodgers take your nuts i'm scratching my puss yeah
um um i i take a clump of shredded organic
freshwater from tj's like it i put it in my
mouth i'm chewing it and i'm like oh delicious
i'm like oh that doesn't taste too good this
tastes weird though that tastes very weird what am
i eating i look down huge lump of green mold oh i
ate a huge lump of green swallowed it swallowed
it so then what were you just waiting panicking
i i was like i was just alone like making noises
like that in the kitchen and i looked and like
some of it's good and some of it's bad because it
shredded i saw it and i saw a big green lump and
i'm like that's what i just tasted and i started
dry heaving i opened up the uh faucet and i put my
tongue on and i kept going like taking water and
swishing it and spitting and swishing and spitting
it out but it already got digested i tasted
the mold i swallowed the mold the mold is in my
stomach now still in your stomach right now it has
to be uh yeah i mean i don't know if it's in but
you have no but but nothing it tasted disgusting
and i was like that tastes peculiar and then i
kept getting more prominently tasty isn't it
like bad like what happens if you eat mold can
you die what happens if you eat cheese with mold
on it probably nothing though some people eating
mold can cause allergic reactions in rare cases
could be poisonous even causing vomiting diarrhea
dizziness internal bleeding so just in case be
sure and cut the mold off now that was where i
was going with this right okay after i ate it
and i had an adverse reaction i spit i dry heat
and i rinsed my mouth out i had the shivers and i
actually opened a small can of diet coke for taste
right to get it out of the way birth control
meal three meal sorry so uh but i have done this
i have seen mold on a piece of bread or a piece
of cheese and i've cut the mold out and eaten
the rest of the cheese business as usual is that
though is that am i a lunatic have you done that
does it stand to reason if mold is forming
somewhere it could be forming elsewhere but it's
not visible yet and it could be inside because
i've just carved the cheese right off and i've
gone ahead and eat the rest of the cheese and i've
done that my whole life and i'm someone who is a
germ guy i don't like things like that i get i
don't have a strong constitution i have you know
i have a stomach of steel but i'm queasy in my
brain right so for me you wouldn't think i would
do that but i've done it and and i only realized
that after i ate the mold right i was like well
i cut mold out and eat the cheese i wonder if i
should even be doing that your thoughts do you
do it do you not do it am i a psychopath lunatic
do you think this is something that everybody does
i i think i don't think our psychopath lunatic i
don't i do think it's maybe something that a lot
of people may do me personally if i had moldy
cheese which i don't really have that much i'd
only call cheese to begin with but let's say you
can't even be in the situation because you only
need hot cheese well let's say i i've seen moldy
bread yeah if there's a piece of mold bag goes out
i'll i'll roof it i mean i'll throw it out on the
garbage but i mean i literally if we were walking
in the street and i bought bread and i bought
bread that i looked at molten i may genuinely
throw it on the roof really i would never in a
million years cut out a piece of the bread or cut
around the cheese get the mold off and then melt
the ch i would never in a million years do that
so i am i'm trish i won't take medicine or drink
milk a day after the expiration date i won't do it
i'd rather just go buy new milk and go buy new
medicine no that's that's the devil's biggest
scam that's the devil's biggest scam right there
first of all milk just smell it milk and eggs
eggs they take can go three to four weeks
past the expiration really yeah this is just
big farm wanting you to turn over what about
what about milk milk smells good i do it but
tylenol they all put a one-year stamp on
it i believe that at most maybe you lose a
small percentage of potency boom that's it read
it it's true it's true the effectiveness of a
drug may decrease over time but much of the
original potency still remains even a decade
after the expiration date inc excluding
nitroglycerin insulin and liquid antibiotics
most medications are as long lasting as the ones
tested by the milk you see what i'm saying they
just want you to buy new [ __ ] they want
you to go back to the doctor they want you
to pay a copay again they want the insurance to
get up you keep taking medicine well no no no
no throw your medicine out at the expiration
date and then if you want to do something
you you decide to do it i didn't tell
you to do anything there's been i began
there's been multiple times in my life
where i've been sick and then went into
the cupboard chrissy cupbert and looked for
medicine and seeing that the medicine was
not that much past the expiration date maybe a
year a couple of months before expiration date
and went back into bed and stayed sick and
wouldn't take the medicine what do you think
until i could go the next day i don't know i
don't know talk me through what your thought
process is i don't even do this do you think that
it might have like um medi like scientifically
expired and then possibly become poisonous
i don't know what it is but with medicine
perfect example a month ago oh a month ago
a week ago i had a really bad stomach ache i
had a really bad stomachache like you know bad
i'm like oh i know pepto-bismol will help me i
go to the cupboard yeah i pull it out i pull
out pepto-bismol the only pepto-bismol i have
is kids pepto-bismol so i say to jasmine i'm like
can i a weak a weaker strength well i said i said
can i take kids pepto-bismol she was like yeah why
don't you be able to take kids pepto-bismol i said
well it's for kids she's like well you were a kid
once i was like yeah but i'm not a kid now right
and she said yeah i'm almost positive you can take
kids pepto-bismol she was like just take three of
them it says take two of them yeah i looked
at it put it back wouldn't take the medicine
because it said kids i don't know i just sat down
and said it's not for me but i don't know after
talking it out with you and thinking about it it's
like of course i could take a children's medicine
but i did i thought i don't know because i don't
know the way medicines work and i don't know if
like sure you always pump the brakes when it has
to do with medicine but medicine i just don't know
but i've never taken anything that's passed
the expiration date or not meant for me like
for example if you were a doctor would you eat a
luna bar yeah a luna bar is formulated for women
i use women the whole thing so do i i use
women's deodorant too i'm wearing women
right now women's spray dove deodorant i use
secret strong enough for a man ph bounce for
a woman made for a woman yeah strong enough
for a man made for a woman yeah that's right
interesting so you're fine with women's deodorant
but when it comes to but luna bars are made for
women which is really odd to me that they cut
out half the they have the potential is there
something in there like does you know i'm wild i
buy it anyway you buy it anyway yeah i'll tell you
what for i would say now two and a half weeks i
guess as you know i've said my uh my girlfriend's
pregnant due date july 4th um i for multiple weeks
just because i wasn't looking i kept taking them
from the back i was taking her prenatal vitamins
thinking it was my men's multivitamins okay so i
i've taken two weeks now mood swings i'm loaded
with folic acid i'm growing a uterus i've taken
i've taken our prenatal vitamins for two weeks
truly two weeks all right so and you didn't know
i yeah because i i would just grab it and
then like basically in in the in the i've said
cupboard now by the way is any other podcast i've
said cupboard now three times yeah in less than
two minutes so i'll say it one more time and
then we're gonna move on from it you went in you
grabbed your cards from the cupboard yeah so and
i would pull out i would just pop pop it open from
the back take one and then but always the label
probably though it was just a multi yeah prenatal
not a prenatal yeah i thought it was the same and
then what is in the prenatal i think it's folic
acid is the big thing folic acid which prenatal
vitamins are specific to the needs of pregnant
and breastfeeding women um they're geared to make
up the common nutritional deficiencies a pregnant
woman could have but they aren't really intended
for women or men who aren't expecting or lactating
so that was a mistake well if i'm saying it now
for being hundred percent honest with
you i'm not expecting but i am lactating
so that's the thing that happens in pregnancy not
that they liked it but they i i saw this recently
the the the breasts just stopped leaking uh
yeah but just start leaking oh yeah no she if
she goes like this right now she can squirt it at
me like like a water that's wild though it's like
wikileaks it's like titty leaks i drank i drank
breast milk before just to give it a taste just
to give it a taste like whether she wants that
stuff coming out or not it's going to leak it's
like it's going to link it's coming out yeah yeah
exactly yeah yeah he didn't did he get pardoned
no don't 10 amazing facts you probably didn't know
about pregnancy your heart actually grows wow your
partner may experience pregnancy symptoms i feel
that i feel i'm i'm having symptom symptoms that
she's having i'm having them like i have pregnancy
brain i feel like there's times where she's like
oh i got pain in my uterus and i feel pain and
wear a uterus of if i have one what would be what
is pregnancy brain just like absolutely crazy
brain is like you can't think of something in
scatter brain and you feel so your brain feels so
mentally exhausted yeah i swear to god i feel that
um babies crying the womb you can crave non-food
items it's possible to be pregnant for over a
year let's break these down one by one if you
have any interest please you can crave you can
crave non-food items what would you crave as
a non-food item like you just crave a baseball
yeah like i just crave an official major
league baseball yeah yeah i explained to
you i'm pregnant yeah it's like you're just
craving like i'm craving gary sinise movies
okay i guess so saying they crave soap chalk or
paper and stones that's sorry that's hey babe
crazy she wanted to eat paper the other day
she had a desire to chew paper i swear to god
she wanted to chew paper that's nuts no paper she
asked me that's odd she said to me she goes you
know what's so crazy right now she goes can you
go to the printer and get me some piece of paper
i swear and i said and i said yeah you're going
to do arts and crafts and delilah she goes no i
just want to chew on it holy cow it's real that's
real i can't believe we just saw that that's real
he she came back you you were chewing on a gary
sinise movie yeah she was eating my freaking dvds
yeah she ate she ate all the merch for my shows
coming up in atlantic city february 12-13 atlantic
city theater christy comedy for ticks comedy.com
that's it yeah um the longest pregnancy ever
recorded was pregnancy of a woman named balloula
bulla hunter from los angeles that's beulah you
know how i know that honey that's the name of
an elephant that had no joke no joke we had
an elephant like season one of the show they hid
my car keys in the middle of elephant [ __ ] and
i had to stand the elephant was standing right
next to me and i had to go through all the elven
[ __ ] to find my car keys the elephant's name
was beulah beulah yeah well and and speak and
elephants have very long pregnancies this woman
beulah 12 and a half month long or whopping three
months longer than the average pregnancy god i
don't know how or why that happened whoa a 12
and a half month pregnancy that's a lot like the
kids just like in there wearing dungarees already
well really a lot of people say pregnancies
are nine months but it's really 10 months
when you're when it's ten months pregnancy i don't
know why we don't go nine months when they're born
why don't we be like ugh you're 10 months old
yeah right instead of zero yeah so really right
now you're 35 and 10 months or whatever i'm 36 i'm
closer to 37 than i think right right interesting
so it was so yeah so we were going back so so go
back to okay so that's a non-cr non-food item but
if we can go back to the things that happened
during pregnancy because there was one after that
that list you had well it said it said yeah
you it's possibly pregnant for over a year okay
babies cry in the womb okay whatever your feet can
grow up to one full size that all makes sense to
me okay taller women are more likely to conceive
twins that's wild what's the reason there maybe
more of a protein maybe if they have more of a
i bet you some type of protein that makes them
tall so like the wnba just shooting out twins
twins all day yeah oh yeah there you go certain
protein released from the liver that is linked to
increased ovulation yeah i knew it was something
over five foot five i guess that's tall i mean
i guess that's tall by the way i i think i i i
there's one scientific what is it there is
one scientifically proven meant to bring on
labor wacky methods of labor passed down through
generations there's actually one which has been
significantly proven to work nipple stimulation
tricks your body into thinking you're feeding
your baby here's the thing i i've told this
before i may have told this on this podcast
but i've told this when delilah my daughter was
being born she was four days late the the doula
yeah the door the doula was like you know like a
jewish um like midwife told me and my girl they
were like the only way if you want to increa if
you want to induce labor in the next hour then
what you need to do is swallow his semen that's
what you need to do swear to god her response
was she goes you have to be kidding me she goes
did he pay you to say that that's what she said
how's that possible she said because there's
properties when when semen is ingested
but straight face wanted you to do that little
jewish woman says if you want to have the baby
if you want to go into labor soon what you
need to do is swallow his semen and she was
like trust me the baby will be born within the
next 10 hours you can i'll you can call her up
and ask you guys like we're gonna take we're gonna
respectfully take a pass we were in the middle of
a we were in the hospital right so i said how am
i supposed to do that right right and literally
time is going by time's gone by time's gone by
an hour two hours and i kept saying like you know
i'm like we could put this to bed right now put
this to bed right now i said i'm ready to go
she said no no no i'm not to do it i would say
maybe five hours after that she finally looks
like started going labor and water broke but she
told me then after she gave birth she was like
you maybe had 20 more minutes she said i would
have just she's like i would have done it in
front of your mother that's what she said she
said i don't care she was like i needed to get
this baby out yeah yeah so all right so there
you go now what what's your take on me carving
mold out of the cheese to eat the remaining cheese
don malt i think that you carving the mold out to
eat the remaining of the cheese i think that you
it's bad you're a tough guy to pin down because
it's like you said for as germ as much of a
germaphobe as you can you know admittingly be
the fact that you're going to eat potentially
molded cheese yeah it's crazy that i do that
makes me think what what do you actually care
about i just feel i don't like to be wasteful
that's where it's coming from it's believe me i
said i was it's like i was born during the great
depression or something oh you could have been
by the way watching a little show on netflix
called chasing death episode reincarnation you
may very well be from the reincar is that right
you may very well be from the great depression
era okay very possible whatever you feel connected
to yeah i feel a guilt in wasting stuff like
okay when i walk out of a room i shut the light
i won't leave a running faucet on you have you've
had a dead goldfish in your freeze for eight years
there you go and another thing is like i'll
keep everything goes in the fridge as leftovers
right and then i i will always try to get
the leftovers done before i get new i just
don't like to be wasteful it's interesting too
because mold is a type of fungus that's used in
like antibiotics so you would think if you're
eating penicillin right yeah wouldn't you think
like if you're if you're if you have an infection
like right now i have an infection on my finger i
could just go eat a bunch of your moldy cheese and
clear the infection you know we should try it i'm
down i don't know if i threw it out what if you sm
smear all the green mold all over your open wound
let's do it for the patreon by the way did i ever
tell you the story of when i got an infection of
my finger in england and what happened i don't
believe so okay i by the way this is this for
anybody and i get that excited i get any everybody
has different stories for for whatever i get that
literally i would there he goes i was certainly
100 uh this is a two-part story i think the second
part you've heard yeah i went to england london
biting my nails nervous on the flight a couple
days go by i get an infection in my finger to the
point where i can't even bend my hand it's painful
i had red streak it's like a serious infection it
it was crazy i'm on the other side i'm across the
pond yeah i'm saying you know anybody out there
who says oh america has the best healthcare system
you know uh national healthcare doesn't work
you got to wait what it fine everyone has
their own personal stories fine fight fine i'm
telling you my story with national healthcare
was on was the the service i got was so crazy that
i thought maybe it was some kind of scheme and i
wasn't in a hospital and i was going to be robbed
or i was on some type of prank show because it was
good it would here's what happened i go in it was
my right hand i had an infection in my finger like
you can't imagine like i said i couldn't throbbing
i couldn't move my hand at the wrist that's how
it was swollen so i had i had to if it cost me
you could inhale a cab no chance i couldn't hail
anything so so um um people always you guys are
so mad that we edit cursing trying it hey babe
that's it suck it we curse everyone curses we hit
curses old dog you need to hear the cursing yeah
i want to go right back to this but
you guys with the like i don't know
the cursing i need to hear the curses it
doesn't matter you stupid piece of [ __ ]
there it is like it doesn't even matter we cursed
all us all we're trying to do is just like hey
i don't want to hear maybe we're just trying
something we're just trying something different
you know the algorithm doesn't look at the 30
seconds the other people curse and they still
get the same ads and who cares yes refocus your
energy reprioritize you need to hear me safe
so so with so with my infected finger i go in
there i can't write with my right hand you know
because my right hand genuinely doesn't work i
have to try to fill out this form with the left
hand so there's a nurse you know there or like a
i think she was a nurse she was dressed in herself
but right there there was basically nobody in
the in the emergency room i think she was a nurse
she had the nurse hat on she's like
she worked at an in-n-out burger spy
and there's just my she was thinking she was
in her shoes well she's the old school nurse
with that hat that looked like
she worked at in-n-out burgers
so like mrs ratchet yeah mrs roberts ratchet great
show shout out is that sora sarah paulson oh okay
netflix she's great great i almost confused her
with the nurse jackie eddie falconi falco who
who's god bless her i know edie was on our show
recently great stupendous guest brain's good right
yes yes also shout out uh catherine narducci
who was the uh actress italian actor you've
seen in many things also was the wife of robert
de niro in bronx tale uh for the last few years
has been commenting on my instagram thinking i'm
a fully open homosexual man so shout out captain
rdj mentioned that for the first time last week i
don't know she told the homeless pimp she's like
i know that guy she's like you know your friend
chris he's great a gay comedian i support him
she's like he's not gay he's kind of why he's got
kids um but thanks shout out captain i'm teaching
um that doesn't mean a lot i know a lot of guys
that have kids that are gay drew well i know three
yeah my i have an uncle gay um kids so so um uh so
i go i go to the to the a e it's called ambulance
i i i just imagine him introducing himself like
that yeah how are you doing charles gay three
kids yeah what it is yeah yeah how you doing so
i go in and i say i say to her she says oh you
fill out this form so so i say i say the problem
is ma'am i said two things one i'm an american
citizen i have a passport to prove that she's just
looking at me she's like okay and then two i said
i can't fill out the form because i can't write
left and she goes dude do what you can love so
i literally wrote like it looked like i wrote my
name backwards i could barely do it i was writing
it lefty i didn't even put in my address i i swear
to god for residents i just put usa okay because i
couldn't right with the hand and then they called
me in the doctor called me in but not even in so
let me try to explain this i'm filling out
the form to the right of the left of the desk
filling out the nurses look at me i'm writing
usa my name backwards the k you know christopher
with a k like a five-year-old the doctor calls me
from the other side of the desk and says um next
patient please next patient please and there's
nobody around there's nobody around so i said
is that me i said i haven't filled out the form
yet he goes don't worry about it so i walk to him
literally i'm still out in the waiting room
imagine in the waiting room of a hospital that
nobody's in and there's a nurse i think is a nurse
dressed like she's serving in out burgers and then
a doctor yes and he goes what's the problem so i
i showed him my hand and i said i i was biting my
nails on the plane which i know i'm not supposed
to do i over explaining i said no i'm supposed
to do it's a bad habit my mother's been telling
me stop doing for years i said but now i have an
infection in my hand and my hand and wrists are
swollen he goes i can see that very clearly and
i said so what you know like should we go in the
back or whatever he goes well are you allergic
to uh any types of medication antibiotics
penicillin anything and i said i could listen to
this all day yeah i swear to god we'll talk about
that yeah i said i said no i'm not he goes okay
he goes well what we're gonna do first is he goes
first i have to lance it and he said it like that
never forget he said lance he said first i'm gonna
have to lance it he said so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna put a little he's got he said he's gonna
put penicillin on the tip and then he literally uh
sal did you have to understand one thing what i'm
telling you i i'm literally i'm standing i hand
to god i forgot what the name of the hospital was
but it was in somewhere in london htg i'm standing
somewhere in london in a hospital the doctor it's
it's it's the the waiting room a vending machine
and the doctor with the lance with
penicillin at the tip of it lancing my finger
then giving so with penicillin on it then he
gave me no pharmacy no nothing like that gives me
pills right there 14 days of pills he
says 40 days of antibiotic pills plus
pepto-bismol or their ver the the pepto-bismol
i forgot what it's called it's like bism
yeah something bismuth pepto-bismol but yeah
but bismuth but yeah but that's but there's
points of the story to that so he gives me that he
gives me the bismuth and he gives me and he says
if come back in two days if you have any type of
allergic reaction he goes we'll give you another
medicine that's it so i'm like i'm like that's it
like whatever he goes that's it so as i'm walking
out i'm leaving the woman says oh love love
love love come back she goes you forgot you've
forgotten something and i said and i said i said
oh yeah i have usa written you know and you know
i'm sure there's a co-pay she goes oh no no no she
goes we give you money they gave me twenty dollars
to take a cab home from the hospital no i swear to
god that's all you that's what they did in england
i don't have to go to a pharmacy i don't have
to give a prescription or do anything like that
i wasn't even a cit i wrote usa uh of where i live
they don't even know my name what are we doing
what are we doing here they gave me 20 to take
an uber home i took the medication like i took
the antibiotics a day later my finger and wrists
are half the size three days later i'm back fully
jerking off no problem and you and how much was
the uber the uber was it less than twenty dollars
i made another deal he bought me lunch
then i'm going to heathrow airport
just in case because i didn't trust because how
i told you i don't trust medications with the
expiration date i won't even take a pepto-bismol
kids i said i'm not taking this funky-ass british
version of pepto-bismol right whatever this doctor
gave me who just you know him and nurse him in the
in and out lady gave me the the the the treatment
on the other side of the counter yeah i went
and i found a store that had pepto-bismol because
i wanted pepto-bishop pepto actually i'm sorry
what what did pepto-bismol have to do with the
cut on your finger in case i had diarrhea from
the antibiotics they gave me a something to
help my stomach got it so i get to pepto-bismol
i get the pepto-bismol i take your time
yeah because it's bringing back memories
they just they get extra content i i i go
to pepto-bismol i you know take it just
in case coat the stomach put it in my bag
forget about it going to heathrow airport
i don't know whenever i leave three days later
four days later packed heathrow airport london
packed south like you can't imagine like squirting
around the lines going around the lines yeah going
around the lines you know whatever all of a sudden
get there packed bag of course put the bag through
gets flagged of course gets flagged i'm like what
the hell do i have and i don't have anything in
it like it's just like annoying like whatever
like i think you're gonna miss your flight pack
the you know tsa equivalent in england comes over
starts rummaging through the bag it's you know
pulling things out pulls out the pepto-bismol
goes what's this and i said uh i said it's you
know it's nothing like you know i said it's i take
antibiotics like it's nothing like you can just
dump it out you guys know what is it what is it
and i said it's it's for like you know if you know
if your stomach doesn't feel good or like some
type of indigestion but like you know it's fine
it's just it's totally fine you can dump it
out i don't need it i'm telling my donation
it's packed right i'm like you i do not need that
like throw it out right now literally 10 feet away
there's another tsa agent just like typing on her
computer and he goes becky becky he turned into a
brooklyn cab driver from the 50s or the 50s yeah
he goes uh what is this love bucky lucky he goes
becky i think her name was back yeah it had to be
becky he goes he goes becky becky he goes pepto
bismol what is it what's it used for and she's
typing she just looks up she goes diarrhea and
then looks back at the screen everybody he she
screamed diarrhea across this perfect airport
he goes oh he goes would you be needing it for
your flight i said no you can throw it away he
goes okay carry on throws it away i zip on my
bag turn around who's right behind me the chain
smokers
what are the odds the band the chain
smokers what are the odds that the chains
are behind you in that moment that's what it is
i follow an english man to the end of the earth
to the end of the english man might be able
to take me away from my family 100 percent so
they fell asleep a woman or a woman it's just the
accent i mean an english man i should clarify all
woman it's not the man that's taking me away yeah
but you were saying you were a man it's it's the
english accent it's something isn't it yeah and i
got to be honest with you any time when i was like
in a bar with my friends or whatever like that
like growing up anybody who had a british accent i
almost wouldn't even believe that i'm like you're
putting on that accent to try to get laid yeah you
have to prove to me i would always ask but name me
five towns in london in england now name me five
towns yeah and and and and then and then they
do it now london bath london bath sussex essex
newcastle sure there's so many yeah all right you
did it well uh people tend to think of foreign
accents more interesting and more sexy says guy
wench a psychotherapist from britain who's long
based in the united states because in general
we tend to value what's less common that's what
it is by the way you and i before the pandemic we
were talking about big time going and hitting the
road in england because i told you that's always
been a dream of mine you've lived you've lived
that dream where you've went all over england
toward the countryside that's what i want to do
with you those are my those are my main peeps out
there man i love england the british are the best
and i want to i want to do a solo stand-up tour
well we should tour together tonight i'll come on
whatever because i just literally i'll just
i'll be your tour manager it doesn't matter
i've always in my life for some reason i've
had a dream and a want and i don't know why
where it comes from we can absolutely have we
can have maybe we do like uh stand up stand up
figure something out i want to be for some reason
i want to go i will we'll tape it we'll take the
pill i want to have patreon patreon i want to have
a fan base in england that's just any anytime i
get a message from somebody from england that
supports my comedy you don't understand like i
feel like i'm living a dream i don't know what
it is maybe it's because the british therapist
said it's just something that's not common i don't
know my only uh my only dealings with fans out in
england is that they've all been amazing exactly
what you want they're just amazing they're just
like really loyal supportive courteous yes like
they they get it you know they appreciate it
yeah i find they're they're more pure like i
just comedy fans yeah yeah no it's beautiful
shout out to england shout out britain who knows
the difference between england and britain shout
them all out shout out great britain shout out
great bridge shout out to the whole united kingdom
brexit shout out brexit shout out i'll i'll even
shut up exit even the republic of ireland i know
there's be you know republicans everybody shout
them all out shout out belfast shout them out
just shout out everything shout them out shout
out another place irishman shout out uh shout out
shetland shout out shetland pony shout out to show
shetland which i just watched on netflix murder
mystery show shetland unbelievable place half of
it they half of it people think belongs in norway
norway is another fascinating thing we don't have
enough time to talk about it though norway had a
problem with the vaccine what oh yeah like 30
people don't know why just in norway though
you know i don't understand that there's a lot of
things in news i don't understand lately i don't
understand the gamestop thing that happened you
don't understand that not really i mean i think
what happened there with gamestop is just a bunch
of nerds came in and just drove up the stock price
of gamestop how here's what i think happened
all right i'm going to take a crack at trying
to explain this yeah do you know what shorting
a stock is i bel i yeah i i'm a fi i'm a major
in finance but uh no i don't so we're shorting
the stock years ago you you buy it so what stock
what hedge fund and i'm probably going to kill
me on the comments for this but we're going to
take it buy it when it hits a certain you put in
an order i think what what hedge fund people do
is they they purposely control the media and
the narrative and say this stock sucks sell
it it sucks and they drive the price all the way
down some cycle saying forget this stock it sucks
don't buy the stock bubble it sucks suck sucks
and they drive the price of it all the way down
knowing that they're gonna buy it when it's really
low and then change the tune and drive it all the
way up and make so much money to change the tune
it's just it's a bunch of people descending on the
stocks yeah it's a coordinated attack exactly the
hedge fund people so what happened with gamestop
i believe is the game they were trying to short
it out they were going to short it out the same
hedge fund people like uh the ceo of robin hood
which is like the investment like they're all
hedge fund people they were going to short suck
they they controlled the narrative a lot of times
they went out we were like no no someone else is
going to control they were like they basically
came on the air one day last week and i don't
know where about you know what [ __ ] gamestop
but they but they don't realize they picked the
wrong you don't mess with game stuff you don't
mess with computer video game nerds so they tried
to short game stop thinking let's drive this price
low low low then we're going to say game stops the
future and blah blah blah you know in a year from
now and we're going to drive it right back like
inside of trading though right but hedge funds
hedge fund people get away with it but that that's
what it is this is the david vs goliath story it's
something that goliath would always do you know
these hedge fund billionaires so what happened
was which they didn't account for is the gamestop
people the game the people who love gamestop the
guys playing their video games whatever banded
together on a reddit forum and said everybody
buy gamestop right now we're gonna lose it drove
the price up from 14 to like four hundred dollars
somebody who had fifty two thousand dollars of
shares of game stuff overnight twenty one million
that's insane yeah so what does that person
have six feet of royal is he done now is it
nobody has that that's true siegfried fishbacher
and roy horn yes yes i spoke out of turn i'm sorry
i swear to god though but now what does that
perk doesn't he have to dump all that to make
that money back if it falls back down no isn't
in essence he doing the same thing because now
he's going to dump it all well no well that guy no
he could cash out all right cash out right now get
make 20 million dollars you can't just cash out
someone has to buy it no no right now it's worth
340 so if you shell that sell the shares of it he
would get the money that means someone has to buy
the three well i think they kind of unionized on
reddit and he's everyone's agreed to hold that's
why they're holding the line as a hey babe to the
hedge fund guys that's why they're holding the
line this is pretty much occupy wall street except
right literally got it wow so it's 340. they said
they're about to do it with another another amc
i think amc because amc is possibly going out of
business or nobody's going to the movies hurting
because nobody's going to the movies which by
the way practical joke was the movie in theaters
during the when the pandemic hit i remember i saw
a shout out imc good partner i met paul abdul
there it was great didn't you did you did you
i tried i tried to i tried to i changed numbers
we changed the numbers to paul abdullah you did
you did it you did not you did too i did but same
thing happened to me with paul abdullah as jerry
seinfeld i was told hey text me anytime you want
left on left on red i do text with paula but i i
you know my my introduction and our relationship
is a little bit different than you meeting her
that night i get it but she's uh top-notch classy
gal yeah no i'll never forget i was literally
at the impractical jokers uh movie premiere after
party i was standing in between paul abdul on
my right chris cuomo on my left uh was eating
mozzarella sticks farted put my plate down left
i never said goodbye to you chris cuomo chris
cuomo the cnn news anchor chris cuomo was at
your impractical job no he was not ask casey
jost i didn't know that we were making i was i
farted next to chris cuomo in the middle of chris
cuomo and paul abdul chris cuomo was at your party
i i you can verify that with anybody i don't know
him i don't know how he got there i'm uh chris was
fascinating chris cuomo you know it was you know
there was so there's this eclectic mix there and
i know we probably got it we're probably over time
eclectic mix but we had uh we had so many people
there we'll get into another time we'll get to
another time what do you do what are you what are
you going to do really because we don't want to go
two over we're going to two over and you got big
yeah and you got big things you got your
your i mean because this here's the thing
here's the thing we can't spend too much time
in this podcast because what we need you to do
is go to true tv right now because the impractical
joker season 9 is out i'll tell you another thing
i need you to stay tuned on true tv because
somebody else has a new show on true tv
that's coming out listen to everybody who
watches that watches the show and watches
true you're going to be seeing a familiar face on
true tv someone just got his own show on true tv
why don't we talk about a little bit we got my own
show on true tv i this is my ninth pilot that i've
done for for the longest i've called myself
chrissy pilots but now let's change that to
chrissy pickups that's the first pilot i've ever
done and been a part of got picked up to air it's
called backyard bar wars with christos stefano
where i'm going to be the host of two friends
competing in their backyards to see who's going
to build a bigger better cooler bar and i just get
drunk and we make fun of everybody and each other
the whole time i i mean look if you know chris or
you don't know chris or you're watching this and
now you chris or whatever you you know what chris
does you know what chris is gonna do what chris
does on that show so the show is secondary chris's
commentary is first and people are going to end
up watching that show i wish i wanted to succeed
i think it's a cool idea but there's no doubt
in my mind let's just let's let's just be honest
yes that show hinges that show is going to be
successful because of you and your jokes and your
riffing and your commentary and your personality
i appreciate it so i i say watch that show if you
want to see more chris and do what he does thank
you i appreciate it because what true tv told
me was it said they were really excited about
this i said because you know impractical jokers
is uh you know season nine you know we're gonna
go season ten we're gonna go we're gonna go all
these seasons they said but you know we know it's
been on a while and they said you know we wanted
to have a show that encapsulates uh upwards
of 25-year friendship with four best friends
pulling pranks on each other through the streets
of new york city and they said we don't think
we think a show where you hosting with two friends
who don't know each other building backyards
and you hosting that show from los angeles is
the exact complementary show that's that says in
practical jokes without saying impractical jokers
so that's why they picked it up they said this
is they said this is like in practical jokers too
and i said listen watching the pilot it's me it's
me and two black guys building bars i said that
looks just like four white guys from staten island
who have been friends for 30 years to me i said
and that said that we should have just called
into practical jokers too i actually said i'm i'm
excited to do the show but it looks a little bit
like joker so and i do a podcast with sal and
i don't want to think that we stole your idea
do you know when it's going to be do you know what
it's going to be on but i think in the summertime
so it might it might it be on like maybe sometimes
they use us to lean into the planet that's the
plan they want to put ours on after you the plan
is right now we're going to start filming in mar
we're going to start filming soon next month and
then hopefully first episode on in the summer
july so you you might go out to la in march and
then i might go out to l.a tomorrow because i'll
be on family feud dude when you go out to family
feud we'll all and then we'll come out we'll go
we'll do the la podcast and we'll hang out that's
right that's that's what we should do that's a
great idea yeah actually i've been to la in so
long we should get on we should go on all of our
friends podcasts if our friends are watching
with podcasts and we know you're listening
brandon chomps podcast he's
a huge fan huge huge fan
yeah so that's it so and listen if you want
to see me if you want to see us live stand
up christy comedy.com atlantic city we got
coming up uh the vogel in red bank new jersey
those shows are almost sold out go get them
and then phoenix arizona february 25th 27th
christy comedy.com also my own podcast chrissy
chaos patreon.com christy comedy enjoy the fun
that's crazy that's it i mean look at i mean
look at what you got going on right now because
come on man we're doing the truth tv pilot in a
pandemic and you're doing all this in a pandyline
thank you bob and i'm having a baby july 4th
due date i mean that's the least of it but
great yeah 100 um uh yeah i'm not on the road
right now will be if those dates will be on
salvo countercomedy.com jokers is on tuesday
night season 9 just started uh 10 o'clock true
tv misery index is on thursday nights 10 30 tbs uh
hopefully dinner party will come back and then uh
i talked about before text me on my community app
listen i still want to talk about this community
up at some point but i never do but and i should
memorize my own number but that's the show is we
always get to something we're never going to talk
about and keep people waiting i'm on a community
app i get your text 718-260-6619 text me sometimes
i answer but i always give you information first
on the app uh that was fun absolutely rip sig
freedom roy look out for the patreon don't be
afraid don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey babe hey babe hey babe